bonjour
ça va pas du tout
pourquoi tu m'as pas rappelé mais tu
vois pas qu'on a rien en commun là
[Musique]
pour autant je ne crois pas monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Juge je sais pas
comment faire pour payer les dommages et
intérêts pourquoi personne me donne
jamais ma chance il y en a qui disent
que la chance ça se provoque c'est pas
vrai c'est une phrase de riche ça tu as
besoin d'argent moi j'ai besoin d'un
chauffeur pendant un mois
[Musique]
je connais peut-être pas grand-chose
mais je m'y connais en vie
[Musique]
tu as tout pour réussir redresse la tête
son ta barrière
je comprends pourquoi tu l'aimes
beaucoup
[Musique]